good morning John is starting to feel a
little bit like spring you may see that
I'm not wearing a coat right now I'm
outside what's pretty exciting stuff for
me oh you know I got to make a video
today but I wanted to spend some time
outside so I figured I'd take you
outside with me I didn't want to start
my house because no offense but I don't
want the entire internet to know where I
live like when I look at my old house I
use have a landline sometimes I get
phone calls from nerdfighters and they
were always really concerned that my my
phone number was publicly available in a
directory of like names matched with
phone numbers I had to like tell these
people that that's what a phonebook is
John I liked the Hunger Games movie I
really enjoyed it but I think it missed
a lot of what it could have been you
know it's a moral story and I talked
about this on my second channel a lot so
you can go watch that video if you want
to but I feel like these days in order
for a movie with any violent content to
get a pg-13 rating you have to
trivialize the violence take all of the
emotion and suffering out of death and
and like is that what we want to protect
our kids from it's been a lot of
controversy surrounding the r-rating of
the documentary film bully which is
about real-life situations in which you
know kids are verbally abused to the
point of wanting to not live anymore I
guess we're not trying to protect kids
from violence we're trying to protect
them from emotion is that is that the
new sister like as long as the killing
and the death and the violence is
completely emotion free it's all good
God so you may have noticed you may not
have cuz my glasses are covering up
pretty well but I have this gigantic
frickin weird zit on my face right now
it's basically like I have a nose like
my nose has a nose now so what my search
for signs of spring I'm what I'm really
looking for is like budding plants and I
haven't seen any I walked bought some
good yards where I thought I might and I
have it I'm going to a specific yard
which i think is going to reward me come
to another place where I filmed the
music video this is the serotonin
building used to be used to buy put
grain on the trains the train tracks
right back there it's not used for that
anymore now it's like sort of semi
defunct artists collective but I taught
of my favorite places in Missoula just
love the look at these old buildings
that you know they feel like they
shouldn't even be standing anymore but
they're wonderful I found it I found the
yard I found the yard I was looking for
you know would have a good stuff so I
guess that's official it's spring some
crocus just springing down on the Fault
in Our Stars you talked about how the
taste of broccoli does not affect the
taste of ice cream or whatever I don't
read it
technology the point being that the
existence of happiness does not depend
on the existence of sadness but yeah to
me to enjoy spring does not depend on
there not being spring all the time like
I guess with spring all the time they're
always crocuses I would still enjoy but
it's something more than that I think
more than anything what I enjoy is the
anticipation like waiting for something
that hasn't happened to happen like a
new video game coming out or new movie I
think it's a pretty human characteristic
that we in a sense care more about the
anticipation of that thing than the
getting of that thing itself that's kind
of why as I've gotten older I've come to
love change where I used to hate it now
it's just exciting it's bringing all new
things that I'm going to get to
experience a new way YouTube an online
video and nerdfighteria and this world
that we found ourselves in to me is like
that like it's always changing it's
always different it's also always been
really cool and really exciting and
really sort of like mind-blowing and
breathtaking that guy just called me a
panda homo
so that's cuz I'm recording a video this
is something that that oh that was my
friend Alli she did not call me or a
homo I would've though the same guy that
called me that one time wow I guess I'd
glad that I have reached the point in my
life where Rangers yelling nonsensical
things that me no longer bothers me so
that's good guys basically just flexing
his muscles at me and saying you're too
free yeah dude I'm different from you
cuz I have the best job in the world
back at the park now John I'll see you
on Tuesday
you